et de l'autre côté se trouvait Daniel McGowan.
Nous avons parlé à travers ces combinés attachés au mur,
et nous avons discuté de livres et de films.
Nous avons fait notre possible pour trouver des raisons de rire.
Pour combattre l'ennui et pour se divertir dans l'UGC,
McGowan avait lancé la rumeur que j'étais secrètement le président
d'un fan club de Twilight à Washington.
(Rires)
Que ce soit clair, ce n'est pas le cas.
Mais j'espère un peu que le FBI croit maintenant que Bella et Edward
sont des noms de code terroristes.
(Rires)
Pendant ma visite, McGowan a surtout parlé de sa nièce Lily,
de sa femme Jenny,
et combien c'est difficile de ne jamais pouvoir les serrer dans ses bras,
de ne jamais pouvoir leur tenir la main.
Trois mois après ma visite, McGowan a été transféré hors de l'UGC,
puis, sans avertissement, il y a été renvoyé.
J'ai publié des documents secrets de l'UGC sur mon site.
L'Unité Anti-terroriste a dit que McGowan avait appelé sa femme
et lui avait demandé de les lui envoyer par la poste.
Il voulait voir ce que le gouvernement disait sur lui,
et pour cette raison, il a été renvoyé en UGC.
Lorsqu'il a été enfin libéré à la fin de sa peine,
son histoire devint encore plus kafkaïenne.
Il écrivit un article titré :
« Des documents judiciaires prouvent que j'ai été envoyé en UGC
à cause de mon discours politique. »
Le jour suivant, il fut à nouveau jeté en prison pour son discours politique.
Ses avocats ont rapidement assuré sa sortie,
mais le message était très clair :
on ne parle pas de cet endroit.
Aujourd'hui, neuf ans après leur ouverture sous l'administration Bush,
le gouvernement codifie comment et pourquoi les UGC ont été créées.
Selon le Bureau des Prisons,
elles sont pour les prisonniers d'une « signification inspirante ».
Je crois que c'est une très jolie façon de dire que ce sont des prisons politiques
pour prisonniers politiques.
Les prisonniers sont envoyés en UGC à cause de leur ethnie,
de leur religion ou de leurs croyances politiques.
Si vous pensez que cette caractérisation est trop forte,
regardez quelques-uns des documents du gouvernement.
Quand le courrier de McGowan a été rejeté par l'UGC, on a dit au destinataire
que c'était parce que les lettres étaient « pour prisonniers politiques ».
Un autre détenu, Andy Stephanian, activiste pour le droit des animaux,
a été envoyé en UGC
à cause de ses opinions contre le gouvernement et la mondialisation.
Je sais que tout ceci peut être difficile à croire,
qu'une telle situation se déroule maintenant, et aux États-Unis.
Mais les États-Unis ont un lourd passé
de punir les gens de façon disproportionnée
à cause de leurs opinions politiques.
Dans les années 60, avant que Marion n'accueille l'UGC,
elle hébergeait la fameuse Unité de Contrôle.
Les prisonniers passaient 22h par jour en isolement.
Selon le directeur, le but de l'unité était
de « contrôler des comportements révolutionnaires ».
Dans les années 80, une autre expérience appelée
l'Unité de Haute Sécurité de Lexington
détenait des femmes liées au Weather Underground,
à Black Liberation et à des groupes indépendantistes porto-ricains.
La prison limitait radicalement les communications,
utilisait la privation de sommeil
et l'éclairage constant pour une soi-disant « conversion idéologique ».
Ces prisons ont fini par être fermées,
mais seulement grâce aux manifestations de groupes religieux
et de défenseurs des droits de l'homme, comme Amnesty International.
Aujourd'hui, les avocats de droit civil et le Centre des Droits Constitutionnels
contestent les UGC en justice
pour privation du droit à une procédure équitable,
et pour exercer des représailles envers les prisonniers
pour leurs discours religieux et politique.
Beaucoup de ces documents n'auraient jamais été découverts sans ce procès.
Le message de ces groupes et mon message pour vous aujourd'hui,
est que nous devons témoigner contre ce qui est fait à ces prisonniers.
Leur traitement est un reflet des valeurs prônées au-delà des murs de la prison.
Cette histoire ne concerne pas que les prisonniers.
Elle nous concerne aussi.
Il s'agit de notre engagement pour les droits de l'homme.
Il s'agit de faire le choix d'arrêter de répéter les erreurs du passé.
Si nous n'écoutons pas ce que le père Berrigan décrivait
comme les histoires des morts,
elles deviendront bientôt nos histoires à nous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Tom Rielly : J'ai quelques questions.
Lorsque j'étais au lycée, j'ai étudié la Déclaration des droits,
la Constitution, la liberté d'expression,
la procédure équitable et environ 25 autres lois et droits
qui semblent être violés ici.
Comment est-ce possible ?
Will Potter : C'est la première question que l'on me pose
tout au long de ce projet,
et pour faire court, les gens ne sont pas au courant.
Je crois que la solution à tous ces types de situations, à tout abus de droits
dépend vraiment de deux éléments.
Elle dépend de la connaissance de la vraie situation
puis les moyens et l'efficacité de proposer un vrai changement.
Malheureusement, avec ces prisonniers,
les gens ne savent pas du tout ce qui se passe,
puis ils font déjà partie des populations marginales
qui n'ont pas accès à des avocats,
dont l'anglais n'est pas la langue maternelle.
Dans certains de ces cas, ils sont très bien représentés,
mais il n'y a pas de conscience publique sur cette situation.
TR : Le droit à un conseiller ou l'accès à un conseiller
n'est-il pas garanti en prison ?
WP : Notre culture a une tendance
à penser que, lorsque les gens ont été condamnés pour un crime,
peu importe si cette accusation est bidon ou légitime,
tout ce qui leur arrive après, est justifié.
Je pense que c'est un récit très nocif et dangereux,
qui autorise ce genre de choses,
tandis que le public ferme les yeux sur la situation.
TR : Tous ces documents sur l'écran étaient de vrais documents, mot pour mot,
absolument identiques, n'est-ce pas ?
WP : Tout à fait. Je les ai tous téléchargés sur mon site,
willpotter.com/CMU et c'est la version de mon discours avec notes.
Vous pouvez voir les documents sans les petits fragments.
Vous pouvez voir la version complète.
Je me suis appuyé sur des documents de source primaire,
sur des entretiens avec d'anciens et d'actuels prisonniers,
avec des gens qui gèrent cette situation tous les jours.
Comme je l'ai dit, je suis passé par là, moi aussi.
TR : C'est un travail courageux.
WP : Merci beaucoup. Merci à tous.
(Applaudissements)